[Applause]
when it comes to your orgasm or holding
your orgasm do y'all like count
like to i try to count things in the
room like i would count
oh man i count the nails
and then um if she is making any sounds
whatsoever i lose all distraction
or i lose my distraction yeah but i try
to count like the nails or the screws in
the wall or count the seams i
really try to get uh into a arithmetic
wait you see the fibonacci sequence i go
into a fibonacci
oh you're like a beautiful mind it
really is that's right you don't want
her to
you say she makes any sound oh it feels
too hot yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's [ __ ] it up it's different
absolutely
yeah y'all rather than girl not make any
sound no no i wouldn't rather it
when i feel really good shut it up yeah
yeah
i put it on yeah i put in airpods
i listen to my face
like you start to like see them really
getting into it that's the tricky thing
that's why i [ __ ] this iphone
that was broke no but
that's the netflix thing
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
my [ __ ] was full mass bro sunday noon
yeah i mean full match what do you think
about when you try to stay up
son i'll just be letting that [ __ ] go yo
come on what are we talking about
really right this is about religious
life you know what i mean because
pleasure isn't the
the yeah i'm getting out now don't y'all
feel pathetic
yeah i feel pathetic every time i'm
[ __ ]
yo akash really figured out life if you
start fat and then you get skinny
everything's successful yeah if you
start pathetic with sex
and then get slightly less likely that's
pathetic it's a win
everybody disappointed out this [ __ ]
you ain't alone so you were the most
buddhist person ever
or hindu i don't know what it is but
it's zen yeah you know what i mean but
like instead of constantly wanting more
you start out
with all of it and then or whatever it
is nothing and then if you get a little
you feel good that's a brilliant way of
going through life
is that buddhism is that buddhism yeah
so really you never try to last like
what's
like what's like i mean hold on
sometimes when you're gonna come quick
and you're like [ __ ] i can't come this
way what's the longest though to you
guys taylor i don't want to hear it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so go so you're never trying to stretch
it out there's another
not you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah
no i think if i if i'm trying to stretch
it out i'll like stop you know what i
mean we'll do other stuff then i'll come
back
but oh hold on taylor oh that's a good
move international
so you do yeah in a mission we'll have a
little intermission and then you'll go
down brief intermission
and you go down yeah we'll do other
stuff you know what i mean whatever we
do
get some snacks maybe yeah go back to a
little fourth place i
feel like a loser doing that [ __ ] like
when i'm about to buzz i'm like hold on
hold on and i just start like sucking on
titties well you don't say hold on
yeah yeah i go like this
i need a 20 second she'll be like too
big is that full or is that 20.
not full let me get through
i need a commercial break for real
what's your technique pull ups i'll just
jump on the bar and start lifting
in prison
and i don't know where this came from
back in the day i just would think of
baseball
because it's so boring yeah and so i
would like think of it like
i think like players like that
that's how latino allen and so i have to
like picture myself like running the
bases and [ __ ] like that
and like i really if a noise happens
[ __ ] now i'm running into [ __ ] or
something like that like it just can
throw me off but if i stay thinking
about baseball sliding into the
house up there like are you [ __ ]
kidding me are you kidding
either that or having tv playing in the
background and then i'm just
concentrating on the episode have you
all ever closed the tip of your dick
like a toy purse and just didn't let
them come back you just pulled the skin
over here
yes it's a drawing tuck yourself in a
bed
you got a string bag all right i got my
jersey in there i got my cleats okay
we're ready to go
oh that'd be kind of lit yeah can y'all
please answer the question what's the
question
never stay in the villa what is lasting
to you can i can i tell you this taylor
this is what lasting is i'm gonna be a
hundred percent serious yeah tell them
last thing is after you come
yes no matter if you come in two minutes
i lasted if you come in
20 minutes i lasted boom but when you
come
that's when the clock that's when the
clock starts going and then it's just 15
seconds more the exact
job is done bend it over get to kraken
hey hey there your back looks dry
oh what a shame oh what a shame
why don't we do something about that
some cetaphil
like a cream or something like that oh i
thought that's when the plants are made
that's cool that's the powerhouse of the
cells
so the girl comes two times at least
come on with all this like
it's like it's crazy how greedy are you
y'all
that's what we do as a team yeah
out if you say you can't last whatever
your girls are good you see the rock on
my girl
that's going down bro how long do you go
down look at that how long can you use
that you think how long can you use it
what the rock that's done that's already
over no that
diamonds last forever
that's your slogan
you mean like how long can i use it to
get out of [ __ ] yeah um
i don't know i don't know bro
but you got to lean into how beautiful
that [ __ ] is like sometimes i'll just be
looking at it like god damn that's just
fire in it
you should just make comments just
randomly i do okay i do i harass that
ring
i i abused that ring
it's like walk away somewhere right now
seriously that ring got ptsd yeah
yeah mark what's your strategy
uh no no rules i was yeah no real
strategy really i was trying to do the
math thing for a while
yeah and then honestly one thing that
did help is just talking what do you
guys think this is going to sound
something like some serial killer
i was listening to this podcast i'm
talking about the indian farmers
now she could tweet with confidence
[Music]
no it's kind of cool so i'll just be
like yo so what's your plan for the day
is so tight i didn't like it it was kind
of cool i didn't like that
what don't tell us it's cool it is cool
okay i'll teach you guys about sex
whatever you guys want to know
sit on daddy's lap
switch the angles y'all just start
having a conversation
during sex it's a good thing you would
not have that why because
stop talking taylor because y'all be
talking during sex
don't go there don't go upstairs
what
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like an escape room yeah
escape the room that you lock yourself
that's what you said you do though you
go over the top yeah i know
like man just don't talk about it
nobody's talking about his dad and i was
like
is it though i took it personally i took
it personal bro
and then i went surfing why are you
doing this but you dead ass though
yeah i tried it once it kind of worked
what did you talk about
what was your conversation go down
though yo taylor you didn't i think i
didn't
try it like it goes i don't understand
that how
does it what is it it's a gift from god
what as you get older you really realize
how true that is
but it's it's a gift from god sometimes
go limp
dicks oh son you know hard to believe
hardship yeah
then on the vacation when i started my
dick started getting hard again for the
first time like three months
it's like the waves in lanai
and it's historic park it was history
i was out there making history bro like
a kid
dude my dick was hard yeah you know
sometimes it gets hard and you're like
babe let's get this going before
it's nice not like that my [ __ ] was hard
she was like i just gotta use the
bathroom i said take your
time i'm just gonna sit here take a
shower if you need
whatever you need this [ __ ] is hard went
outside with the heart came back in hard
showing it off son i literally was
outside on the porch
the room had a porch no big deal
no big private shuttle
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know screaming at my girl take your
[ __ ] makeup off i've got some snacks
but in all seriousness yeah i think the
conversation thing works if anyone's
looking for uh
where like nah i'm gonna try to just
imagine that i mean it's also kind of
hot cause it's like oh we're just like
talking like oh yeah i'm not doing
anything
you know only a movie that's the most
catholic way to go about yeah
seriously we're not doing the thing
that's a sin yeah yeah we're just doing
god can't see us right now because we're
just chit-chatting he's listening like
oh
they're making plans for the afternoon
i think we really tricked him keep your
skirt on he won't know what's happening
you